for a show that it's unbelievable it's
been off the air now how long a long
time a long time okay okay don't make me
mad okay 2004 all right so it's been on
I've been off since 2004 and the show is
it's almost worldwide more popular than
ever yeah I was reading today that in
the United Kingdom they have something
called friends fast it lasts six weeks
six weeks friends or no I think it's 12
weeks actually the twelve it's 12 weeks
12 weeks where people who are who are
just friends maniacs recreate like
scenes I don't know what they did I
don't even know what they do what do
they do
I don't know I don't know you should go
I should go we're order brothers we
should find out if they should know
about it shouldn't they there's no I
mean is there money to be made from
[Laughter]
that's so disappointing but I looked
into it and yes there's money there's
money for all of us I know I don't know
what they'd do would be funny those like
they dress up as what it's not like
interesting costumes I don't know very
good costume design yeah get me wrong it
was good but would would you ever go I
mean if there was a if there's a
friend's fast in the UK would you ever
go and go surprise or hundreds of
dollars you wouldn't go I don't know
yeah yeah oh that's oh you don't like
crowds no okay no all right yeah all
right all those people are really into
you and want to talk yeah you come on
that would be great
what's wrong with you people I think
that would be amazing I want to go to
friends fest um we could just tell
people I was on an episode yeah the
episode where I played the the the
really pale brother
[Applause]
your swimmer and you aged weird
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you